[Musique]
ce film c'est l'histoire de luang quand elle
était petite
c'est son expérience pendant la guerre et
le long c'est une amie très chère que j'ai
rencontré il y a 15 ans en lisant son livre
m'a beaucoup parlé de ce pays donc  d'une
certaine manière, je le fais pour elle pour sa
famille pour le Cambodge et tout
aussi formatique pour qu'il apprenne qui il
est et connaît son peuple c'est une
histoire non seulement de ma famille mais l'histoire d'une
nation que j'étais '  Je ne vais pas le laisser tomber à
qui que ce soit
Audrina porque la nación hace
effets spéciaux coquelicot Rebecca ouais l'émission
s'appelle acoustiquement présentatrice de l'empire J'ai
vu une grande fille qui dirait que Hosea
max travaille dessus depuis le
début, il est dans la production avec laquelle il
m'a aidé  le scénario et ce n'est pas
seulement parce que c'est mon fils c'est parce que ce
film est à travers les yeux d'un enfant et
nous avons tous dû nous ouvrir un peu
plus et être comme des enfants je ne voulais
pas voir un enfant partir  à travers la guerre je
voulais savoir ce qu'un enfant ressentait et sur quoi il se
concentrait  d sur ce qu'ils ont vu
la philosophie importante de sokka un poème sur
Tracy Mallory pour gérer un
régime de destruction provisoire totalement Tara elle a
frappé sur TJ n'est pas des créatures extrêmes
du congrès de Thompson le cambodgien
totalement funk à propos de l'arbre si vous
ne savez rien sur le Cambodge et si vous filmez
vous gagnerez '  Je pense juste que ces gens
qui souffrent pour vous récompenser penseront que
ce sont des gens vraiment intéressants
leurs racines et leur personnalité leur
humour leur amour de la musique leur culture
c'est tout ça ça doit être à la
fin cette lettre d'amour au peuple cambodgien
[  Musique]
vous